oui
[Musique]
on peut couper sur l'aspect très fier
la cartomagie maurice duda en a fait sa
spécialité pour son spectacle
l'illusionniste devient richard marcus
maître de la triche aux jeux d'argent
une histoire où se mêlent magie il est
humain heures perdues vous savez la nuit
à las vegas dans le désert
il ya des trous dans le désert
et il ya des tas de problèmes d'intérêts
dans ces trous
rouges eux c'est un as on sait sa vie
dans les grandes lignes mais ça a été
annoncé et bien sûr le support magique
c'est à dire les tours de magie sont là
juste pour étayer le propos pour
illustrer l'histoire ça a été mise en
scène comme un road movie en fait à la
scorsese pas donc si nos téléspectateurs
connaissent les films casino ocean's
eleven voilà on est on est dans tout cet
esprit là quoi c'est un spectacle de
magie théâtre à dix durant 25 ans
richard marcus a amassé plus de 5
millions de dollars grâce à ces
techniques muni d'un simple jeu de
cartes il joue manipule et démontre ses
méthodes avec une dextérité envoûtante
une passion pour la discipline commencé
à l'âge de 10 ans je vais vous verrez
magicien la télévision avec josé garcia
mort avec gérard majax avec avec tous
ces magiciens la de l'époque les puis
ensuite il ya eu il ya eu gilles arthur
il ya eu bernard ya eu bernard bilis
j'ai découvert et qui a été le gros
déclic pour moi ça fait rêver et canton
on a la fibre en principe on la lâche
pas pendant plus d'une heure maurice
duda vous plonge au coeur de la capitale
mondiale du poker ses casinos et 16
escrocs richard marcus et sa légende
sont à découvrir jusqu'au 29 octobre
[Applaudissements]